hello reject nation I am the Greg Alva
this is Carl ermine the Kyle ermine
that's right a fan Theory YouTube
channel go check out his channel he puts
in a lot more thought than I have ever
done in my entire life so we're gonna
watch the trailer today for tragedy
girls it's a horror comedy comes out in
a couple weeks and several people have
said to watch this
and today is page from the day shout out
it's gonna be for JT will give you a
shout out after the video you know like
by ourselves
[Music]
I listen
[Music]
are you worried that the killer will
target users of your infamous blog we
will not take any more [ __ ] from this
series
[Music]
okay sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well it just stopped recording for no
reason period because she has a period
so this is all so they can get more
followers it's a great idea man I can't
tell you how many youtubers I thought I
can give I'm Oliver
Louis I'm almost on the verge of this
YouTube's algorithm has really affected
ya maybe's made specifically for people
who were affected by YouTube's out that
does look fantastic in a lot of
different ways that one quote was
exactly what I was thinking
it's like Heather's meat scream oh yeah
100% when I was thinking I'm like yeah
that's that's that's what came to mind I
like both of those my love scream oh yes
I've only seen Heather's once and I was
a kid so I don't really remember it but
I remember enough to be like this kind
of reminds me of Heather's you know
there's a lot of these movies coming out
now about like social media and oh yeah
session with it scream 4 was the first
time that they made that that was like a
thing yeah like oh this matters it's the
only way to be famous is to yeah that's
nice and twisty it's a great type of
serial killer plot especially with like
them being the killers and no one's
suspecting yeah because they're covering
it so why would they be the ones that
they're covering yeah it has a little
bit of a taste of jawbreaker too like
the look and the feel and what's going
on except in this one they're not
covering continually I love like dark
disturbingly entertaining comedies such
as this because it definitely has a
quirky offbeat kind of surreal vibe
about it which is like a Heather's or a
scream but it seems even more amplified
especially for audiences today and it
looks like it's gonna be very violent I
was so disturbed like a nose off the one
fit oh yeah yeah and that's and I
already mentioned this but that's
definitely negasonic teenage
warhead from daredevil or rabbit yeah
daredevil daredevil and she was in the
defenders hold ever held a brand it's
just a fascinating tale to me of these
people creating this story of serial
killers and then creating the flip side
to it of them covering it and they're
following growing off of it and then
it's very meta because it's like when
you hashtag tragedy girls or hashtag
tragedy girls movie you're like this is
about social media then all these things
it's exaggerated tale of people's
obsession with what you'll do to get a
bigger following yeah and people will do
ridiculous things and they'll fake
things all the time this could happen in
real life which is you've heard or read
a story on Yahoo have like girls
actually doing this that actually she
was storm no way yeah she was storm and
x-men apocalypse at sushi was its
negasonic teenage warhead and storm so
as cereal so it's an x-men yeah I love
when yeah yeah I love with carpet
characters crossover in movies that are
not complex we just had Jeremy Renner
and Elizabeth Olsen in river now we're
getting yeah it's fun hahaha yeah
there's a slight bummer to me that they
reveal they killed Josh Hutcherson at
the very beginning of this movie it's
kind of a bummer but I'm like but if
you're gonna market the movie and give
us the plot you kind of have to show us
that you know yeah it took me a moment
to realize wait they're really killing
yeah yeah yeah that's oh this is no
that's actually what they're doing here
this seems like it's gonna be a good
month for horror movies in the month of
October man oh yeah well guys what do
you think of tragedy girls have you ever
killed someone to try to get a bigger
following on social media if so comment
below and leave your social security
number oh wait a minute before this
video wraps up shout out to JT JT is a
man from Hawaii he's a Japanese man and
we did a Google hangout with
this kind of guy that when he talks he's
kinda reminds me of Johnny Depp in the
sense of like whenever he answers a
quick he listens very yeah he's no
personality no he really listens and
absorbs the question and then we'll even
if it's a yes or no he'll just really
take it in and JT I could totally see
being the kind of guy to do this because
you know it's like he's kind of quiet
it's a little unnerving and if he were
to be a serial killer killer I'd be like
yeah JT's totally a serial killer if a
cops came to me said you had a Google
hangout I would not see a comma be like
honestly I think it's his JT guy can you
still pledge on patreon though while
he's in jail because there so I'll
totally turn them in if not I'm gonna
say now got your back buddy subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell Kyler man is the collar man on you
twitter and instagram check out his fan
theory youtube channel it's totally
worth my time